anna guarda sono disperata certa è un
disastro non studia non aiuta in casa
non fa niente sa tutto giorno attaccata
col telefonino
ma lo so lo so sarebbe un piccolo genio
ora sei fortunata sei fortunata avercela
una figlia così
guardala carlotta è un angelo è una
ragazza studiosa diligente altruista
ordinata educata
ogni volta che viene a trovarmi mi aiuta
a sistemare a lavare aspirare a pulire
barda è un gioiellino di ragazza è
proprio guarda sono orgogliosissima di
mia nipote
[Musica]
cosa è successo potrebbe né un sistema
ma lo sistemano sistemano sistemano si
scotta quello è il bicchiere del mio
servizio buono su ogni cosa che tocchi
rompi io non so io non so più come fare
io tu non puoi essere mia temi e basta
[Musica]
lei si è fatta male vigile preferito da
mamma chi se ne frega non se ne
accorgerà neanche tu piuttosto dimmi 6
tutta gonfia qua adesso tranquilla
prendo il ghiaccio stai ferma qui non ti
muovere sedi carissima guarda ti
richiamo tra dieci minuti perché devo
risolvere la questione molto importante
grazie grazie ad un positivo
ci ho pensato bene tu sei in punizione a
vita
adesso ti chiudo in casa fino a quando
non inizia a studiare seriamente
ok a prendere voti decenti ok mamma ti
giuro
allora non mi prendere in giro io mi
sono stufata va bene alla tua età ero la
prima della classe adesso mi tocca avere
la figlia a cena ma ti rendi conto
quanto appreso sarebbe tutte le volte
che mi chiama lanna che devo fingere di
non sapere quanto vai bene a scuola è
sua figlia la più brava della classe ma
che figura mi faccio io ma che figure
non amore della nonna ma non è possibile
perché sei intelligentissima ai
tantissime capacità secondo me che lo
dico io c'è qualche professore che ti ha
preso di mira e adesso chiamo la scuola
ci penso io tranquilla
ma lasciala perdere quella lì dai
tranquilla ci penso io mamma come sto
nota guarda è meglio che non ti dica
quello che penso
ma a me piacciono ma certo che ti
piacciono perché è quello che va di moda
note lo fi senza pensare che guarda
sembri un pagliaccio te lo devo proprio
dire stai veramente male otta veramente
male
nonna guarda come sto
massa è bellissima neanche ti riconosco
semplice cono sembri una diva di
hollywood ma guarda che i morbidi ma che
belli sembrano naturali naturali disse
il mio amore varda sembra proprio il tuo
colore non sembrano tt assolutamente
belli belli corposi brava e si guardi
l'avvocato mi gilera il contratto
revisionato a breve fame e in qualsiasi
caso e in qualsiasi caso le dicevo la
questione è la nonna
ciao amore come stai tutto bene un po
fame tranquilla e da stamattina via
buccino solo per te cosa mi hai fatto di
buono allora ti ho fatto la lasagna che
informo e quale di le cotolette colature
a di patate con le preferite
posso solo dire un po riposarmi che sono
sardo revai riposati appena è pronto ti
porto tutto di lei amore di non vai nota
allora forse non ci siamo capiti
domani alla verifica se ancora cui
guarda la tele tubi dynamo ancora due
minuti due minuti un partigiane resto
fili in camera studiare subito
ecco vedi quella e sua figlia ma lei non
lo sa perché è stata adottata
sì sì stiamo sto guardando qua la
telenovela
no lei di là chi studia certo e l'ho
mandata a studiare sinistro tranquilla
otto mani a sistemare che lasciato un
casino scuola hai detto riposare per una
mattinata a scuola fila subito a mettere
in ordine è quando poi sarà nel mondo
del lavoro capirai cosa vuol dire essere
stanchi e gente che dal mattino alla
sera sta in ufficio e tu ti lamenti su
camminava haiti la fila ma pensa te
8 perché non va di là sistemare che ha
lasciato un casino scuola riposare un
pochino stanca cosa allora forse non ci
stà capiti io sono tua madre e io ti
dico quello che devi fare
eh no cara la bambina è stanca e deve
riposare che ha studiato tutto il giorno
è semmai tu scusami aiutami a sistemare
le sue cose no disgraziata
[Musica]